Karl Lieberherr has developed the Law of Demeter,
which suggest limits on the classes that can be refered to by a given method.
Imagine that you are writing code for a method m of an object o.
Your code can refer to features of other objects or
features, either in attribute or a method.
The question is, what other objects is it reasonable for you to refer to?
Answering everything can lead to typely, tightly coupled systems.
Instead of everything,
Lieberherr proposed some limits to the objects that can be referred to.
You can refer to features in O itself.
You can refer to features.
In classes that are the, the classes for the parameters that go to the MethodM.
You can refer to any objects created or instantiated within M, and you can
refer to the objects O's direct component objects, that is, its attributes.
Obeying the Law of Demeter reduces coupling, but
sometimes requires introduction of extra wrapper classes.